hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his short essay plato's doctrine of
truth Martin Heidegger is engaging with
the famous Platonic allegory of the cave
and he's asking and answering this
really important question one that is
all too easy for us to take for granted
because it's one of those things that we
all know the answer to at least if we
studied the allegory say in an intro
class
what is the allegory of the cave
fundamentally about and it's made even
trickier because Plato has already given
us what looks like the definitive
interpretation of the allegory of the
cave and Heidegger here is going to
suggest that all of that is true all of
that is is relevant but there's actually
more to the picture than Plato is giving
us as a matter of fact he's trying to
tell us that there is a transformation
of metaphysical and cultural
transformation in the very conception
the very human approach to truth that
runs not only through Plato but from
Plato all the way down to the late
modern present so we want to start out
by looking at what it is that Heidegger
is is saying Orient's this this study
and he begins by talking about you know
what does this story mean says Plato
himself provides the answer he has the
interpretation immediately follow the
story and then he tells us about that
for a bit and and we get this what he
calls an allegorical correspondence
between shadows and fire and things and
all these interesting parts of the story
that I think most of us are already very
familiar with and if you're not you want
to go and check out Plato's allegory
then come back to this so Heidegger is
going to tell us the allegorical
correspondences that we've enumerated he
runs through a number of those between
the shadows and realities experienced
everyday
between the radiance of the cave fire
and the light in which the habitual and
closest reality stands between things
outside of the cave and the ideas and
the Sun the highest idea he says these
correspondences do not exhaust the
content of the allegory so what does he
mean by saying that there's more to the
story there's there's a greater let's
call it interpretation understanding
that we can actually derive from it but
it's going to take some work to do that
and you'll notice that I've put things
on the board in this way with Plato on
one side and Heidegger on the other I
don't do this to suggest that Heidegger
is opposed to Plato I'm saying that that
Heidegger is showing us something else
that that is there in Plato but is not
being sufficiently emphasized so we
could say that the allegory the cave is
really about two things
it's about Paideia this this greek term
then we're going to talk about in just a
moment which you can understand is
education
Heidegger makes the case that the German
building is closer to it and then we
have a lethea
which we can generally translate as
truth but Heidegger is going to have a
different a different interpretation a
different rendering of that term that he
says is closer to its its root so what's
the contrast here Plato himself tells us
that the allegory of the cave really is
about Paideia and its opposite pedasi
the you know having an education or
being educated and being uneducated
being uncultivated you might say
Heidegger is going to tell us that
that's true but the allegory of the cave
is also equally about truth and it's not
only about truth it's about a
transformation in the understanding of
truth a transformation in the human
approach to truth
so Heidegger tells us some really
interesting things here about education
in relation to Plato he says that the
the reason for the this process of
becoming educated why why it has to be a
gradual process he says is that the
turning around that's involved there's a
turning the soul around it has to do
with one's being and thus takes place in
the very ground of one's essence now
Plato is going to use this this language
of the soul Heidegger is going to talk
more about the human being and and what
his or her essence is but it's it's
really all the same idea here so he goes
on and he says that what Paideia is is
the process whereby the human essence is
reoriented that's a really key idea re
oriented and accustomed to the region
assigned to it at each point the idea is
that as we are becoming educated it's
not just an influx of knowledge it's not
just being provided with skills it's not
something that could be reduced to
algorithms instead it is a
transformation of the human being
but not a transformation in the sense
that we're like being turned from Latin
to gold you know from one substance to
another rather we are finding parts of
ourselves or even the whole of our self
being you might say turned inside out or
turned in a different direction that's
one part reorientation but then this
being accustomed to the region assigned
it and this is this is something that
Heidegger is going to point out is
really a important part of the allegory
of the cave that things take a certain
amount of time so he says this is what
Plato calls Paideia
and he says the word does not lend
itself to being translated as Plato
defines its essence Paideia means and
we have some Greek terms Peter Iago gay
whole' a state suitcase so what that
means is a turning around a driving in a
different direction of the entirety of
the soul or if we want to say the mind
or the essence of the human being
Heidegger characterizes this is guiding
the whole human being and turning around
in his or her essence so he says this
means that Paideia education if we want
to translate it as that is a movement of
passage it's not something that it could
consist say in certifications it's not
something that we can have a wonderful
theories about that we teach in
education departments rather it's
something that is involving the human
being at his or her core so he likens us
to the German building which is often
translated as education or culture and
he says that this is a nice you know
cognate it's close to it but it's not
entirely the same he says that what we
have to do is conscience concentrate on
the original meanings and and building
his useful building comes from this this
word for image build right so he says we
have to forego the misinterpretation of
it it means two things on the one hand
formation means forming people in the
sense of impressing on them a character
that unfolds but at the same time this
forming of people and this is what he
takes as being particularly platonic and
also characteristic of Western
metaphysics sense Plato we have the role
of what we can call a paradigmatic image
or a prototype for build in German right
so he says the formation means
impressing a character on people but
using a paradigm to do that if you know
you're Plato this probably sounds very
much like platonic forms at this point
and you would be entirely correct in
assuming that there is one other thing
that that Heidegger stresses that I
think is really important about this
Paideia aspect
he says that Paideia is a movement of
passage from up high die Oh SIA into
Paideia from a lack of education into
education or formation or whatever we
want to call it so the last thing I'll
say about this part is Heidegger says
genuine education takes hold of our very
soul transforms it in its entirety by
first of all leading us to the place of
our essential being and accustoming us
to it so it doesn't just lead us to a
place it has to remain with us in that
place and help us get used to it help us
learn how to get by in at that place and
what is that place it's what is most
essential to us so the allegory of the
cave works in part by saying that at the
start we don't actually know what's
essential to us we're mistaken about
that and as education proceeds I'm
taking the person out of the cave up
into the sunlight where they see real
things rather than merely shadows they
are finding what is most essential and
they are coming out of Kyoto SIA but
this this connection remains and that's
very important to do not lose sight of
let's talk now about truth so Heidegger
says that the allegory of the cave
illustrates the essence of Education
well then he says listen that's fine but
I want to do something else with it I
want to add a bit to the interpretation
here he says we're now going to attempt
an interpretation that points out a
platonic doctrine a teaching about truth
about Ali theta
Alethea truth so he says is this a
illegitimate move are we burdening the
allegory with something foreign to it
are we adding something that we
shouldn't be adding here are we doing
violence to the text and he says no
we're not doing that because what's
going to be revealed in this of course
Heidegger has done this already ahead of
time so he can say this is what he calls
the hidden law governing that what the
thinker says about this transformation
in the very essence of what truth is
taken to be how truth is understood
so Heidegger is saying that there is a
understanding of truth prior to Plato
that the Greeks had and that after Plato
and all the way through Western
metaphysics we're going to find this
transformed understanding of truth this
is transformed interpretation governing
things and that it's particularly there
in Plato in this very allegory of the
cave
what are we moving away from Heidegger
says that the essence of truth really is
originally something that we can call
unhidden this and this is coming from
the word all right
Laith a refers to what is hidden or what
is forgotten or what is covered up he
enumerates a number of different ways
that all that you know this forgetting
or covering or hiddenness can can occur
ah is a primitive it's taking away so
it's bringing something out of its
hiddenness into visibility into the
light into intelligibility making it
present for us and this is what
Heidegger takes as being really
essential to truth before Plato and all
the meta physicians get their hands on
it after they get their hands on it
he says it gets turned into something
different there are several different
ways of characterizing this adequate co
intellect Assad ray is a scholastic way
an ADD equation or correspondence
between the mind the intellect os--
and the things we might also substitute
you know at similar you know at equation
or correspondence between language and
things or language and the mind or pick
whatever we we like but that's a very
different conception of truth and he
says that the allegory is changing this
so he says the question we want to ask
going forward is from what perspective
does Plato approach his determination of
the essence of unhidden 'us how does
Plato make sense out of truth as
something dynamics something that
happens not just something that's
possessed by say statements but
something that we can encounter
something that we can find within
ourselves when we look at things in this
way we're going to see that the Platonic
conception of Paideia is going to be
connected with this Platonic conception
of a lethea and that these two are going
to be connected together in the allegory
and in subsequent Western metaphysics
you